today on the matt wall show as we have
seen for many months now many people in
this country and across the west are
eager to give up their basic rights and
liberties for fear of covid they insist
that we should all live in the same way
fearful and oppressed like them but i
have a different solution which i will
suggest today also president biden warns
that those in the path of tropical storm
henry uh they must remember remember to
wear masks when the storm hits yes he
really said that wear masks when the
storm hits and the media claims that
there is a rising trend of anti-mass
parents physically assaulting teachers
but the trend doesn't exist they're
making it up we'll look at the facts
today and finally the cancel mob has
taken a special interest in the hunt for
a new host of jeopardy why do they care
so much well we'll talk about that today
and much more on the matt walsh show
well the situation in australia seems to
get worse by the day and by situation i
don't mean covet itself as far as the
virus goes they're experiencing only
four deaths per day in a population of
25 million
and four deaths per day we should note
represents the worst of it that's the
most they've seen this year and probably
the peak or close to the peak of the
current wave by the way four deaths in a
country of 25 million represents point
zero zero zero zero one percent of the
population
and this has been enough to justify a de
facto martial law with nearly all basic
human rights and freedom suspended and
public health authorities are now
warning citizens that they're not
allowed to even speak to each other in
public
and this is all horrifying enough
but for those who tend to sympathize
more with the plight of animals than
humans perhaps this will get the point
across a report from fox news says a
group of dogs that was set to be sent to
a rescue were instead shot and killed by
local officials officials according to
local reports this was apparently done
in order to prevent shelter employees
from traveling and potentially spreading
infection
a watchdog group the office of local
government says it was informed by the
bork shire council that the dogs had
been shot the incident occurred in an
attempt to prevent volunteers from
another area
from traveling to that location
so they're now shooting rescue dogs
perfectly healthy dogs for fear that
caring for them may result somehow in
the spread of a virus that kills a
whopping .0001
of the population per day
meanwhile the government is issuing
arrest warrants and the local media are
delivering urgent news bulletins about
coveted positive people who commit the
crime of leaving their homes this is
very real this is not a parody or
anything it's hard to tell the
difference a lot of times these days but
watch this
it's those doing the wrong thing driving
our record case numbers among the most
concerning cases a covet patient who's
tonight on the run from a hot spot
police and health authorities have
issued an urgent appeal
anthony carram knows he's covered
positive when he steps into this public
lift already breaking so many rules he
doesn't bother to cover his mouth as he
sneezes and splutters the 27 year old is
still infectious but has gone missing
from his wentworth point apartment a
warrant now issued for his arrest
this 27 year old chap
who apparently has expressed the view
that he doesn't care less whether he
spreads the virus
is one example of the worst of the worst
the worst of the worst
not murderers not child rapists
the worst of the worst
the guy who has the virus and got into
an elevator by himself we should know
but as always the most terrifying thing
is that the people
are cooperating with all this going
along like mindless cattle now in
fairness a certain brave minority have
spoken out and protested this dystopian
insanity but most citizens of the
country seem to be just falling in line
the image that many of us outside of
australia have of the kind of plucky and
fearless
steve irwin-esque aussies who wrestle
crocodiles for fun
has taken a serious hit which is a
tragedy in its own right
but then who are we to judge in america
we are overrun
by scared infantile cowards in this
country as well a sizable portion of our
own population would happily go along
with all of the measures that have been
put in place in australia and then some
the fact that most of those measures
have not been put in place in this
country at least not yet has caused many
of our fellow countrymen real distress
they they have more freedom than they
want
they're begging the government to take
freedoms away from them
and they certainly believe that you have
more freedom than you should have
and their fear and panic is is really
tearing the country apart even more than
it was already torn apart before all
this started the wall street journal
this morning reports on how coveted fear
has turned even families against each
other they report quote
weeks of rising cover 19 cases have
hardened divisions within families
communities and friend groups over which
members have been vaccinated and which
have chosen not to do so hannah
lindeborg wanted to pull out all the
stops for her daughter's second birthday
in july especially after the pandemic
derailed the family celebration for her
first
birthday last year the second birthday
would be the first big gathering with
extended family since cove 19 came into
their lives miss lindeborg said adding
that she looked forward to hosting
everybody over at her home in saint paul
minnesota when she learned some of her
family members had chosen not to get
vaccinated
it just went downhill from there
from family gatherings to weddings to
workplaces vaccinated americans are
drawing new sharper lines around who
they choose to spend time with amid the
rise of the highly transmissible delta
variant and the unvaccinator are growing
testy over being excluded and feeling
judged for exercising the right to make
their own health choices the divisions
are straining relationships among
families neighbors and colleagues miss
lindebook 30 years old is an attorney
and mother of four including a
five-year-old son with asthma she and
her husband tried to figure out how to
host everyone while telling the unvaxxed
ones to remain outside they considered
uninviting the unvaccinated ultimately
they just canceled the party
now there are many cases like this of
course
the vaccinated people never seem to
pause and think about the fact that
they're so terrified of the unvaccinated
if they have faith in the vaccine
then why should they be so scared of
unvaccinated people
if they have little faith in the vaccine
that might explain their terror of the
unvaccinated i guess but it also takes
away their right to be angry at them
if you don't believe the vaccine works
how can you blame anyone else for not
getting it
does it work or does it not work
if it doesn't work then why should
anyone get it if it does work why do you
care if other people don't get it
this is a real logical problem for these
people but
they are fearful and panicked and
fearful and panicked people never think
through these sorts of things or
anything else
there's very little thinking going on
just raw trembling emotion and those
emotions are taking an increasingly dark
turn more and more uh the panicked
people are openly wishing death on those
who do not share in their panic every
day you see another video just like this
one let's watch this
my daughter just called and her
boyfriend has tested positive
he's the only person in his work that's
wearing a mask
out of you know 300 people
and now my daughter who's 29 weeks
pregnant is at risk
uh
i hate
every single
one of you
who refuses to wear a mask to protect
others i
hope this virus finds you i hope it
finds you and i hope it
destroys you because the people that are
trying to do their part in this are
getting sick because of you stupid
ignorance
morons
so
please get vaccinated
real catch there you gotta feel sorry
for her husband
i mean if she has one still
um whatever number she's on
so he he was vaccinated presumably the
the son-in-law
and and was wearing a mask
and he still got sick
okay and if any but if anyone suggests
that perhaps those measures don't work
all that well
if anyone were to suggest that
uh and so they declined to partake in
them
you label them ignorant morons who
deserve death
do you see the problem here
well no you know and i we can't really
expect this screaming harpy to see the
problem she's just looking for someone
to blame
same can be said for one of my fellow
nashville residents melissa joan hart
formerly the star of sabrina the teenage
witch and clarissa explains it all for
you 90s kids she is now sick with kovid
and explaining why it's all the fault of
unmasked school children it's all their
fault that she's sick even though she's
vaccinated uh let's watch that
and i got coven
i am vaccinated
and i got covered
and it's bad
um it's weighing on my chest it's hard
to breathe
um one of my kids i think has it so far
i'm praying that the other ones are okay
i'm mad
really mad
because we tried
and
we took precautions and we cut our
exposure by a lot but we got a little
lazy and i think as a country we got
lazy
and
i'm really mad that my kids didn't have
to wear masks at school
and i'm pretty sure that's where this
came from
and
i
nothing i can do about now
my little one luckily wore a mask every
day because he was used to it from last
year
and he came home bragging every day mom
i wore my mask and i was so thankful and
now if he does get it i can at least
tell him
he was a superhero to those in his
classroom because he protected his
teacher and his
classmates from it
she's uh
doing everything she can to stay healthy
and by the way you notice how she says
uh well they
i'm mad at school because they didn't
require my kids to wear a mask well
they're your kids
you could have required it i don't think
you should require that of your kids
i think it's abusive to put your kids in
in um in a mask but she obviously
doesn't think that
and so just just imagine that she's
blaming that why didn't you require my
kids to do this thing
but it's not her because it's all your
kids fault for not
muzzling himself at school
and yet apparently
she said she's doing everything she took
precautions
but those precautions did not include
canceling her trip to disney world
a look at the instagram page where this
video was posted reveals that just
before this video she was gallivanting
around at a massive crowded theme park
could that have been the source of her
current ailment no of course not it had
to be your fault
this brings me finally to an important
point
and i know this is fruitless now
um but but i'm going to say anyway again
speaking for myself
i am aware
that covet is endemic
that there will always be new variants
uh so when i hear about what they've got
delta varane and there's the lamb
variant and
um
you know it it it's just like it's it
sounds like frat row at a at a
university with all these different
variants and everything
and i know that
and there's always going to be new ones
and i know that i will inevitably be
exposed
to the virus at some point if i haven't
been already
i know that i'll contract covet if i
haven't already
and even if i have or i do i might get
it again at some point in the future
just as many people get the flu multiple
times throughout their lives i mean
natural immunity is a thing but it does
there's no reason to think that it lasts
forever
now this is not an argument against
taking precautions
washing your hands is a good idea in
general basic hygiene is a worthwhile
practice in general
eating healthy getting plenty of sun
plenty of vitamins these are all good
lifestyle choices and also good
protection from cove at least in its
most serious forms as for shots lots of
people get flu shots every year which is
a fine thing to do if you want just
getting the cova vaccine is a fine thing
to do if you want with all that
established
i choose to live my life and carry on as
as as normal
if i had any reason to believe that we
could literally get rid of covid
completely by taking whatever steps
then maybe my calculus might change i
don't know
but that's not the situation
we can't it's here and it's not going
anywhere
i don't like it
but that's the truth i wish it weren't
true but it is
i'm not saying kova doesn't exist
or that it's all made up
or that i know for a fact it won't kill
me
it probably won't kill me
it probably poses little threat to me
but probably isn't definitely
so that means that it could kill me just
as i know many other things could kill
me and yet i choose to live alongside
that reality within that reality and in
spite of it that's my choice
if you feel differently
if you simply are not willing to accept
the mild risk of covet mild for most
people anyway
then you are free to make different
choices
you're free to stay home as much as
possible nobody is forcing you to go to
disney world
nobody is forcing you to go anywhere
really
in fact one of the blessings or curses
depending on how you look at it of
modern life is that it enables you to
rarely leave your home you can have most
things delivered to you including your
groceries lots of people can work from
home if you can't i know not everybody
can um but but then if you have to go to
work that you're free to go to work and
rubber gloves and a gas mask
i mean why not if you're that afraid of
it
then why not do that you you can do that
no one's stopping you
and then come right home every day
no social life don't go out to any
restaurants don't don't go to any theme
parks go don't go to the movies
don't don't go for a walk don't do
anything just stay in your home
my point is you are free to drop out of
society for the most part or completely
cower in your home
hide under your blanket
lock the door who knows coven may be
able to pick
may be able to turn it i don't know if
they figured out how to turn the
doorknob yet but make sure you lock the
door
get some dead bolts
live in fear of this virus determined
that when you die
which you will
something other than that will be the
thing that takes you out
now i think that's an insane way to live
i think it's a tragic way to live i
think it's a cowardly and disgraceful
way to live but nobody is telling you
that you can't live that way
what i'm telling you is that rather than
trying to impose your paranoia on the
rest of us
rather than insisting that we all be
hypochondriac lunatics like you
why don't you just do your thing
okay live your truth as the left always
tells us
this is your truth right
so go ahead and live it nobody's
stopping you
let the rest of us live our
lives we have made our choice
we'll deal with the consequences
you make yours
and good luck to you
why can't that just be
the solution well i know why it can't be
this is all a rhetorical question
because really controlling other people
is the whole point in the end isn't it
let's get now to our five headlines
take a step to the side for a moment and
talk about charity mobile if you have
not yet switched over and made charity
mobile
your provider then you're really missing
out because charity mobile is the
pro-life phone company and they are a
company that shares your beliefs and
isn't going to cancel or censor you for
them they're also supporting you know
your causes out there in the culture
other mobile service providers are
neutral at best when it comes to the
causes you care about and many of them
are far worse than neutral but charity
mobile partners you with partners with
you to automatically support the
pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and that means that uh every
day
you know when you're simply paying your
bill you're also giving to a charity
into a cause that's so important in the
culture charity mobile also makes it
easy to switch you can keep your
existing phone number and you may even
be able to keep your existing phone
they're making it very easy for you and
when you do switch you get excellent
coverage with nationwide service on
america's most reliable network 5g
phones are also available now new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping so there's no reason not
to switch you got to try to switch to
charity mobile and support a company and
causes that you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention the
offer code walsh
so i got to tell you about this i know
i've told you
several wardrobe malfunctions that i've
had over the last few weeks uh a real a
real trend
and th this one i guess i got to just
tell you about this because it's sort of
like the culminating one and this was my
my real wake-up call that maybe i am not
qualified to dress myself in the morning
so you know
my wife you know she gave me grief last
week because i was wearing the tan on
tan outfit tan shirt cam pants
and uh that apparently you can't do
so yesterday we're about to go to church
and you know my wife says if you've got
a shirt for church i'm gonna go iron
some stuff so give me your shirt and i
handed her a shirt which i had recently
purchased
and it was a like a blue shirt
and to me it was just a blue shirt with
some patterns on it it's kind of like
non-descript patterns but i was going
for something you know you don't want to
go with a solid tan on tan something
with a little bit more character
something with more
um a little bit more if i if i could
dare say pizzazz to it
and i hand it to her and then she starts
laughing hysterically because it is
according to her it's kind of like a
floral pattern
it's a flowery shirt she said
and then she started saying how it looks
like something her dead grandmother
would have worn
and she starts calling me a grave robber
and we're having this discussion about
the shirt and then my my one and a half
year old daughter unprompted she was i
know she was not set up for this
and she's you know she's just recently
learning how to speak and put sentences
together she walks into the room
and she points at the shirt and she says
mommy's dress
and i just got absolutely owned by my
one and a half year old daughter and
this is where i realize no matter what i
try to do
go with the tan on tan that's not good
solid color not good try to go with
something a little bit more
with a little more character to it
i end up wearing
an old lady's dress by accident i mean
this is this is the situation i'm in i
think i think i just have to accept it
except when you have a problem
and reach out for help
all right joe biden has a lot of
problems
one of which is a non-functioning brain
so here's a very real tweet from joe
biden in reference to
tropical storm henry he says to those in
henry's path
don't forget that you may need to seek
shelter while we're still battling
covenanting in the delta variant so wear
a mask and try to observe social
distancing to everyone across the
country don't get caught by the next
storm get vaccinated now
wait somehow i i i i miss the second
part of this uh the this thing the third
sentence there i missed when i
originally read this
don't get caught by the next storm get
vaccinated now
so what the vaccine is a i would like to
think that he means storm in a
metaphorical sense covet is a storm but
you can never be too sure these days is
he claiming
that the vaccine actually protects
against hurricanes
it really is a wonder drug in that case
i'm not sure if that's what he's
claiming but he is saying
that when planning
for potentially devastating storm
flooding maybe your house is destroyed
uh make sure you wear a mask
that's that should be now it's
interesting here that
if if you gotta run to a shelter because
of massive flooding
and um
you know a potentially fatal situation
what he's saying is
make sure to keep in mind social
distancing and wearing masks even even
in the face of an emergency situation
always keep that in mind
and yet if you go back and and you refer
back to the picture
of the afghan
refugees
who are being loaded onto planes in
afghanistan and brought to our
neighborhoods here in the united states
and especially that first picture where
you got 600 afghans and that crowded
onto that plane
and some unfortunately on the outside of
the plane as well most of them you know
young young males of fighting age but
but
no masks among them
i assume there was no covet testing done
there was no requirement for a vaccine
passport
no masks
crowding them onto this plane and
bringing them over here
so in that situation they can say well
we don't have time to worry about any of
that
which makes sense in a vacuum
yeah it would be crazy in in that
situation to worry about oh i gotta make
sure everyone has masks on
and yet for american citizens in an
emergency situation
you got to run to a shelter with a
hurricane bearing down on you a tropical
storm buried down you they want you to
worry about the mask
and it's not just joe bidel we can't
blame only him for this this he is uh
following marching orders from the cdc
because if you go to the cdc page
on preparing for a hurricane
this again is very real
here's what it says preparing for a
hurricane follow these important
hurricane preparedness tips from the cdc
first tip
prepare for a hurricane take basic steps
now to ensure your safety should should
a storm hit i like how their first
the first step in preparing for a
hurricane
is to prepare for a hurricane
prepare for a hurricane step one prepare
for a hurricane oh well thank you cdc
that's that's some some very useful
advice step two
get a covid19 vaccine as soon as you can
so that is the second thing they want
you to do
in preparing for a hurricane is to get
is to get a covered vaccine
again the question is do are they
claiming do they think that the vaccine
actually protects against hurricanes
i would like to assume they can't
possibly be claiming that but i don't
think we can assume that um also
speaking of masks
this pediatrician i want to show you
this
a pediatrician
uh
is scott hadland is his name dr scott
hadland
and he put up this post on twitter a
couple days ago with this smug
grin where he's got his mask pulled down
and he says pediatrician here kids
should wear masks in school that is all
thanks
i love the that is all at the end
he is decreeing this
the pediatrician has spoken
well he said it so i guess
this smug bastard right here says the
kids have to wear masks in school who
are we to question
but then you notice something you can
you you can barely see it but right
behind him on his bulletin board in his
office
there is a a little chart there with
what appears to be like a pink elephant
do you see that
sort of a pink elephant wearing a suit
that is
if you zoomed in on that you would see
that that is the gender elephant
which is something that's used
uh with kids to indoctrinate them into
gender theory it's one of the many
creepy
sort of worksheets that they hand out in
school sometimes
sometimes it's a gender elephant
sometimes it's the gender-bred man
but
you talk about
a uh
not exactly a shocking twist
that this guy telling kids to wear masks
in school also happens to have the
gender elephant hanging in his uh
in his office
i i wouldn't personally let that guy
anywhere near my kids
i mean any pediatrician saying that kids
should wear math saying that it's a good
idea for kids to wear masks for seven
eight hours a day i'm not gonna let them
anywhere near my kids
they've got the gender elephant hanging
in their office on top of that that's
that really is the icing on the cake
isn't it
all right number two msnbc has this
screaming headline very startling it
says the next coveted war school vaccine
and mask mandates
far-right extremists anti-massacres and
now parents are fueling a rising pattern
of violence against educators
a rising pattern of violence against
educators well that's very that's pretty
startling isn't it
there's a there's a rising pattern
of teachers being physically assaulted
nobody wants to see that it's a terrible
thing
um
and it makes you want to click on the
article and read some more
except what of course what msnbc wants
you to do they want you to click on the
article so they get the clicks but they
don't want you to read it
they want you to see it react to the
headline
click on it and maybe do a real brief
skim and then share it that's all they
want you to do
they don't want you to
really bear down and read each sentence
but we're going to do that right now
and you tell me if something seems a
little bit amiss here they remember
they're alleging a rising pattern of
violence against educators and here's
what the article says
a california elementary school teacher
was hospitalized this week after
allegedly being assaulted by a parent
who is upset about the school's mass
mandate for children the attack is part
of a rising pattern of violence against
educators by parents anti-massacres and
far right extremists targeting schools
that champion critical race theory
transgender rights and other issues over
the past several months
let's see but with the school year
getting underway across the country it's
the war on masks currently igniting
parent protesters and in ways that are
rapidly turning violent
anti-mask protesters and far-right
extremists like the proud boys have
shown up at school board meetings to
protest mask and vaccine mandates
heckling and threatening masked people
accusing educators of child abuse and
calling on schools to unmask the
children well first of all
i don't know who would go to a school
board meeting
and accuse
say that it's child abuse to put your
kid in a mask i don't know who i don't
know what sort of extremist would say
such a thing
but i condemn that individual whoever
that happened to be
anyway continuing says in texas repeated
altercations between parents and
teachers led to a superintendent's
letter to parents asking everyone to be
kind and stop fighting mask wars in our
schools in a colorado district sheriff's
deputies were stationed outside schools
on the first day of classes to ensure
protests did not disrupt student
learning
in some ways the violence we've seen
outside schools reflects broader
tensions rippling across the country
you've noticed we're reading all this
they keep saying rising trend violence
where is the violence they haven't
actually told us about any incidents of
violence except that one
and uh
now trying to jump ahead a little bit
here where do we get to the actual
violence
uh then they start telling us over a
third of parents across the u.s do not
think schools should require
unvaccinated students and staff to wear
masks
maybe that's the violence they have they
have a
their opinion is a form of violence
is maybe what they're saying
um
and
you keep reading you keep reading and
that is really it
that one
a rising trend of violence
and they have one case
and actually when you read into that one
case here's a local news report from the
nbc affiliate talking about that case
where a teacher was allegedly assaulted
and here's what they say about it
a california elementary school teacher
was allegedly assaulted by a parent
wednesday during an argument over their
child having to wear a mask
um
the gibson who's the
[Music]
district superintendent tori gibson said
the male parent verbally assaulted the
school's principal when his daughter
walked out of a school building wearing
a mask
when a male teacher stepped in
the situation escalated and a physical
altercation happened resulting in
injuries
now that is a far cry from saying that
that um
that this was an assault where the
parent was solely to blame maybe he was
i don't know
but all we're told is that this this
parent showed up he was upset about the
masks justifiably so
he confronted the principal justifiably
so
you know we we don't know the full
content of what he said because we're
not told that
and then a male teacher steps in and an
altercation happens
and the teacher is
is injured in the process
so this sounds to me like a fight
between two guys
and one of them got the better of the
fight
who started it
who hit first
was was the parent reacting in
self-defense was he hit first we don't
know
so all that to say we have
maybe
maybe
one teacher who was assaulted in the
entire country one maybe that's a big
maybe
no others
and this justifies for msnbc and other
media outlets a rising trend this
justifies the claim of a rising trend of
violence against educators
in fact it gets even more absurd than
that because in this article from msnbc
when in the first paragraph they say the
attack is part of a rising pattern of
violence
it's a hyperlink and you can click on
that rising pattern of violence and it's
blue you know you click on it it brings
you and of course when you see that link
rising pattern of violence and it's in
blue
and that signals that oh it's a link and
you assume you'll click on the link and
it will take you to some other article
documenting other cases of violence and
yet you click on that link
and it takes you to a cnn article about
the exact same one single incident that
happened with this elementary school
um
and it oh i know i will say in fairness
later on in the article from msnbc they
do mention one other case where a parent
allegedly uh ripped a mask off of a
teacher's face
so if we want to call that physical
assault then we've got and that's a
stretch
then we've got maybe two
maybe
and this is a rising trend
how do they justify that
well because they have no problem simply
lying
but also technically
you know
arguably two is
it's rising it's more than there were
before
yeah it could be the start of a trend
this this is a 200 percent increase over
uh the month before
but they hope it's the start of a trend
that's really what they're going for
here
they want to see more of this
a lot more
um and and really the point is that they
can't
the arguments that the so-called
anti-masters are making and once again
we have to stipulate that
um
the people who don't want kids to be
forced to wear masks in school
they might be anti-mask and that they
they don't want to wear a mask they
don't think anyone should wear masks or
anyone should have to wear masks that's
where i am personally
um but there's a great number of of
these people and i've talked to many of
them
who have no problem with masks they even
wear masks themselves they just don't
think kids should be forced to wear them
for seven hours a day
but the argument made by that side which
is labeled the anti-mask side
um
it's an argument that
they have no response to
they don't have the data on their side
they don't have the science on this
their side they know that
and so all they can do instead is paint
us as violent extremists
and make up these narratives of teachers
being assaulted left and right
okay the daily mail has a story that's
uh is also not a parody though though
again it's very hard to tell these days
some police in the uk will now be
driving rainbow cars
it says police are painting rainbows on
the side of their squad cars in a bid to
beat online hate crimes and give
confidence to the lgbt plus community
critics have said forces should be
focused on real issues such as knife
crime and that the colorful cars might
seem less intimidating to the public you
think so
but deputy chief constable julie cook
says that the this is a really good idea
and she was interviewed about this and
she explains why it's important to have
rainbow police cars and here she is
the rainbow cars the hate crime cars
whatever we want to call them they are
part of our vehicle fleet so you know
we're always replacing vehicles they get
um all of the police sort of insignia
put on them as normal but there will
normally be then something added on that
is to do with the rainbow side of things
but they're out there as normal patrol
vehicles sometimes people will ask us um
how can you afford to do that you know
that's not right to to spend money on
putting a rainbow on a car well actually
the cost is quite minimal but the
confidence that it can bring by just
having that rainbow on there and people
say to me you know the impact of seeing
the rainbow is so huge and the idea is
that the cars are there in the
communities generally on normal policing
patrol just again to show the community
that we want you to come forward if
something is happening that you know
isn't right then we absolutely want you
to come forward so it is there to try
and give confidence to our lgbt plus
community but also to other
underrepresented groups
well there's nothing that would give me
greater confidence right than seeing
police officers driving around in
literal clown cars because that's what
they look like they actually look like
actual clown cars
and what could give you more confidence
in that
she says that people say to her the
impact of seeing the rainbow is so huge
she claims that's a direct quote from
people really is that what people say
you know uh
constable the impact of seeing that
rainbow is so huge such a huge impact
do they actually say that because i
don't think they do
but um this is
when we as we've discussed many times
and this you want to talk about a real
rising trend
um
that i've warned about is that is that
you know in our culture now and across
the west
the most important thing of course is a
person's psychological state
is their their psychological well-being
and um and you know and of course not
their actual psych because actual
psychological well-being is important
it's not the most important thing but it
is important
but what we consider psychological
well-being is just
you know affirming however a person
happens to feel in the moment even if
it's not good for them in the long in
the long run and since we've decided
that this is the most important thing
then it kind of makes sense that the
next step now is that police officers
their primary job is to protect
not to protect the physical health and
safety
of the public but but to primarily
protect their psychological health
and that's where the rainbow police cars
come in that's why you're going to have
police rolling up in rainbow cars
upon reports of uh you know someone
saying mean words or being being mean
online to somebody else
this is
absurd and and uh embarrassing and also
kind of hilarious in a very morbid way
but it's also a logical extension
at the same time
all right next uh you may remember
shachiri richardson she was the woman
who was disqualified from the olympics a
sprinter disqualified because she tested
positive for weed
and she was made into a martyr for this
everyone felt sorry for her she was uh
you know she was a martyr then she was
she was appearing in nike ads and that
sort of thing
um
and
you know
in truth
does it make sense to disqualify
olympians because they tested positive
for smoke and weed uh marijuana is not a
performance-enhancing drug so does it
really matter does that rule make a lot
of sense i don't think it does but
it was the rule
and she knew that
so this is a person she she knew that it
was the rule for the olympics
that she was going to get tested or she
could get tested
and she chose to uh roll the joint or
pack the bowl anyway
so whose fault is that
it might be a dumb rule a pointless rule
but you know the rule is there and if
you really care about the olympics and
pursuing that dream then maybe you just
lay off the weed for a few weeks
possibly
hard to see her as the victim but that's
how she was painted
and then and then the olympics happen
and she starts kind of she's being very
annoying about the whole thing as one
would expect she starts gloating online
when the american women who were
actually in the olympics were struggling
at one point the you know the relay team
was struggling and she tweeted miss me
yet
and then there's this big build up
to her return to the track after her
suspension but it didn't go well espn
reports sprinter cherry jefferson or
rather richardson's return to the track
after not being allowed to compete at
the tokyo olympics did not go as she had
hoped but she stressed that she's not
done richardson finished last in a field
of nine runners in the 100 meters and
withdrew from the 200 meters
um uh on saturday her time of
11.14 seconds in the 100 was well behind
winner elaine thompson hera
who was the olympic gold medalist from
jamaica who clocked
10.54 seconds for the second fastest
women's time in history so she came in
after all of this buildup
and all of her gloating but how we
missed her presence in the olympics she
comes in
dead last which i think is just great
and hilarious but here she is after the
race and she's still not done gloating
let's watch this
this is one race
i'm not done
you know what i'm capable of count me
out if you want to talk all that you
want because i'm here to stay i'm not
done i'm the sixth fastest woman in this
game ever and can't nobody ever take
that from me
well they can
actually the sixth fastest
woman that isn't look don't get me wrong
that's an accomplishment to be the sixth
fastest but it does sound kind of funny
for someone to be bragging about it i'm
the sixth fastest ever
the sixth
fastest and nobody could take that from
me well i mean they can't i mean someone
else could become the six fastest you're
not you're not as it stands right now
you're not
look i'm not saying that um
all female athletes
are
irritating self-aggrandizing
people like this but there's been a lot
of them especially surrounding the
olympics
you know a few exceptions remember that
female wrestler who's the olympic gold
medalist she was fantastic we need some
more like we need some more really males
and females we need some athletes who
are not just
absolutely repulsive and annoying
um because that's what we're getting
it's it's just it's impossible
to root for someone like this
because you're not whether it's it's the
olympics or even
you know just watching professional
sports in in you know in an american
league
you're not really rooting just for the
individual you're in the olympics you're
rooting for your country
uh if you're watching the nfl or
something you're rooting for your
football the nba you're rooting for your
team
and so when you have athletes who all
they care about is themselves and
they're very open about that it's just
it was never about you
there seems to be a misunderstanding
so you think we care so much about you
individually we don't it's what you
represented that we cared it's not about
you being special
but when you throw all that to the side
and you say well it's all about me
then you lose all your fans
nobody cares anymore
finally here's uh
the second story like this in as many
weeks first last week there was a there
was a big brawl at an nfl game after
some guys were arguing
and then a woman comes in and throws a
soda at one of the guys
and uh she so these guys were arguing
and this woman comes in from behind and
just chucks a soda into the middle like
like i'm throwing a grenade into the
middle of the thing and this big brawl
starts big big fight and of course the
woman stands back and watches all of it
and then this week on sunday at a
steelers game
a similar kind of situation a woman is
in a guy's face screaming at him it's
unclear what happens
we don't know what led to this we don't
know who's in the wrong who started it
or whatever uh and it's not clear what
exactly happens next but he kind of
lightly shoves her back and says don't
touch me indicating that she had touched
him although you can't really see that
if that happened or not
but then she hauls off and slaps this
guy across the face
and then the man retaliates
and the guy who was with the woman
stands up and starts throwing punches
and he gets knocked out in the scuffle
it's a whole thing
i know you're hoping i'll show you the
footage but uh that would be i think
inappropriate we're not going to gawk at
something like i'm just kidding of
course we're going to show it let's
let's play this footage here this uh
fight
okay so you can kind of see them arguing
and what
and then the guy jumps up because he has
to
now the other guy is wailing on all of
them and now he gets knocked look at
that
he gets just knocked out cold
all right now
a couple things a couple couple points
to make here
first of all
and this goes for everybody involved in
this and again i don't really know what
led to it but
in general you're just trash if you're
getting into fights at football games
i know there's alcohol involved most of
the time but really i mean i don't care
who you are it's a game you're rooting
for a team because they have a certain
colored jersey and a certain mascot on
their helmet it's the most unserious
thing in the world
and most of these fights i don't know if
that was the case here but most of these
fights start because number one there's
alcohol but number two it's a fan from
one team a fan of one team versus a fan
of another
no our team has the better colors
we have a cooler mascot that's basically
what the fight's about
and you're risking felony charges over
that
second point i think more more uh more
to the point
and this goes to the ladies
and i know you already know this
they're all too aware of it but i'm
going to say it anyway
please remember
in these situations
that you are writing checks
that your man has to cash
okay you're not really the one catching
them he's gonna have to so reflect on
that
so that woman screaming at that guy
again i don't know what precipitated it
i don't know who started it i don't even
know who hit first exactly but but
you slap a man across the face
guess who has to live with that decision
not really you
it's the guy who's with you he has to
so you should have a certain sense of
responsibility i think because of that
this man did his duty he stood up
but the thing is whether the woman was
in the right or the wrong who knows
he still has to he has to throw himself
into the middle of that
and get risk getting knocked out
so all i would ask is you know just keep
that in mind
you're at a football game you know as a
woman you start getting in someone's
face and screaming at them
every word you say this is a big check
you're writing
and you're passing it off to the guy
with you
just with great power comes great
responsibility
as uncle ben would say
all right next uh let's read some of the
comments here
[Music]
um
let's see paul says i really hope carrie
underwood makes a submission for the
sweet baby gang anthem now that is great
i somehow i doubt she will but uh
carrie underwood
you know i was hoping that the the all
the huge controversy over her liking my
tweet i was hoping she would say
something about it it would have been
great if she had spoken up and
and doubled down on it but uh i think
she
has said nothing one way or another and
i'll give her credit for that because
most celebrities in her position would
have just apologized and she didn't do
that and so i gave her some credit for
that
and really uh her decision to say
nothing at all was was objectively from
a pr standpoint is the smartest smartest
thing
um
in
most of the time in these situations if
you simply say nothing it will go away
which it has for carrie underwood
so people are upset about it online for
a few days say nothing about it they
move on and everything's fine
um brennan says matt you're the only
person in public life who stands up for
us members of the anti-dog community
please don't give in to the pressure
i i i i can understand that we are a
very very small minority
and i do it does i do get the sense that
i am
committing a form of treason by
potentially getting a dog myself and i
do live with that guilt brennan i want
you to know that
um
and uh graham says matt i agree with you
about men crying but i have one
acceptable addition to the list after an
18-day stay in nicu in which he almost
passed we brought my now healthy son
home to god be the glory well graham
that certainly would be an exception for
crying and uh congratulations to to you
and to your son and to your family and
we'll we'll leave the comments on that
positive note for a change
it can be really hard to keep up with
the news these days keep up with
everything that's happening in the world
and that's why we're trying to make it
easy for you you get a reader's pass and
that's how you're going to you're going
to stay informed about everything that's
happening
and you can get this reader's pass for
just four dollars a month the daily wire
readers pass unlocks exclusive editorial
content that unpacks trending political
and cultural topics penned by everyone
from candace owens to dan crenshaw to
even our very own matt walsh
and you could take a deep dive into
these really important issues stay
informed
and get some perspectives that you're
not going to find from any other media
outlet but the best thing is that once
again with the readers pass you're only
paying four dollars a month and you
could do that right now if you act fast
because right now we're offering a one
month free trial so you can see if you
like it it's a good deal and it's also
never been a better time to take it so
what are you waiting for get informed
get a reader's pass today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
you know one of the hallmarks of any
dictatorial regime is pettiness this is
certainly one thing that comes through
in soldier neeson's account of stalin's
russia or any account of nearly any
autocrat throughout history they are
ruthless
and megalomania tyrants with broad and
usually horrifying aspirations but they
also focus just as much if not more on
the slight and trivial after all
uh you know that you you really have
control over a populist if they will
obey you even when it comes to the most
trifling of matters
if they will not only submit to and go
along with your grandest ambitions but
also conform themselves to your demands
in every minor and seemingly
insignificant way then you have total
control the people are your marionettes
and you are their puppet masters they've
seeded everything to you given up nearly
all of their personal agency this is the
goal ultimately and it's depressing to
see how often this goal has been
realized in different countries and
civilizations at different times in
history and we're seeing this principle
at work of course across the world right
now as we discussed in the name of
stopping the spread of covet and we've
talked plenty about that and we'll
continue to discuss it but right now
i want to focus on something else
because this is also the point behind
what we call cancel culture we've come
to think of cancel culture as its own
thing right a separate phenomenon
but really it's all a part of the left's
overall plan to control and dominate
society
we might think of cancer culture as the
specific mechanism by which
the left imposes itself in those
especially petty and seemingly trivial
ways
that is exactly why canceled culture is
such an important issue and such a
threat the pettiness is the point
the pettiness is power
and speaking of petty it doesn't get
more petty than this
as i briefly discussed on the show on
friday the cancel culture mob has taken
a special interest in the hunt for a new
host of jeopardy
why do they care so much about this
um why does this search for a game show
host matter
well because it doesn't matter
it matters because it doesn't
it's important because it isn't
in this case after weeks of auditioning
potential hosts the decision was made to
bring a guy named mike richards on board
as host now mike richards also happens
to be the executive producer of jeopardy
given that the executive booster of
jeopardy is one of the guys primarily
responsible for finding a host of
jeopardy it would seem that he kind of
went through this whole talent search
only to say uh never mind i'll actually
do it myself
it may even seem like the talent search
was a ruse
kind of a symbolic gesture at most and
maybe it was but who cares they can hire
whoever they want to be host of jeopardy
the decision has no effect large or
small on anyone else's life
well maybe i should speak only for
myself and say that i have never in my
life experienced any form
of deprivation or suffering that could
be traced back to a network tv game show
i can't imagine how anyone could have a
different experience in that regard
say what you want about pat sajak for
example and i like him personally but
even if you don't i can't imagine anyone
in a moment of anguish and despair
crying out damn you pat sajak this is
all your fault
nevertheless
the canceled mob has decided that the
game show host issue is now of urgent
national importance and that's why
once mike richards was anointed the new
host or anointed himself i should say
the news
they immediately set out to destroy him
as if he was a front-runner for the
presidential nomination the mob went
digging for dirt looking for any
skeletons they might find
the reason for their opposition to
richards is pretty obvious as described
in many articles including this one from
the ap it says quote
giving the flagship show to richards
who's firmly in the cookie-cutter host
of a
cookie-cutter host mold of a white
square-jawed young man
struck some as proof of an insincere
effort by the studio to consider a woman
a person of color or someone from the
lgbtq community more than half of the
guest hosts fall into one or more of
those groups
so mike richards had committed the sin
of being white and male that's really
the problem of course alex trebek was
also white and male and everybody loved
him
even the left loved him
but i think trebek was kind of
grandfathered in
he was a beloved figure who became
beloved before it was decided that all
white men are evil bastards the left
kind of allowed him to retain his
beloved status
a magnanimous exception fueled by their
own nostalgia but no such exception
would be granted to poor mike richards
so it didn't take long before they found
what they were looking for apparently
richards had made a few offensive jokes
on a podcast about eight or nine years
ago
um again does it matter that the host of
jeopardy made crude jokes about almost a
decade ago
on a podcast that nobody listened to
is there any reason why this should
preclude him from holding note cards and
asking trivia questions
no but once again the pettiness is the
point
richards not one to break from the mold
immediately issued the standard
groveling apology in a statement he said
quote it is humbling to confront a
terribly embarrassing moment of
misjudgment thoughtlessness and
insensitivity from nearly a decade ago
looking back now there's no excuse of
course for the comments i made on the
podcast and i am deeply sorry the
podcast was intended to be a series of
irreverent conversations between
long-time friends who had a history of
joking around
even with the passage of time it's more
than clear that my attempts to be funny
and provocative were not acceptable and
i have removed the episodes my
responsibilities today as a father
husband and a public personality who
speaks to many people through my role on
television means that i have substantial
and serious obligations as a role model
and i intend to live up to them
that was a statement of course what he
should have said was something like
it's come to my attention that many of
you are pretending to be offended by
comments i made on a podcast that nobody
listened to or cared about until five
seconds ago but i also realized that
most of the offended people are too
stupid to even watch jeopardy in the
first place so what do i care go watch a
sub 95 iq game show like wheel of
fortune instead you dummies
now if richards had issued a statement
like that
i actually would vote for him for
president
but we've yet to find almost anyone with
the guts to stand up to the cancel mob
in such an aggressive way or really in
any way at all
and richard certainly wasn't going to be
the first he apologized
they didn't accept it
and then he was forced to step down from
the roll the same song on repeat over
and over and over again
and it doesn't stop there because it
never does
you see the producers of jeopardy
had already tried to preempt the
inevitable outrage over choosing a white
male
by actually appointing two hosts of
jeopardy they selected a woman actress
mayam bialik who was on big bang theory
and some other stuff i don't know
to host the prime time jeopardy specials
that they plan on doing periodically so
really they they invented
these specials that they're going to
start doing
just so that they could appoint a female
host and then not be accused of
prioritizing you know males over females
they were trying to be equitable and
equal and all that kind of stuff
and that didn't work either the problem
is that biolic is not a person of color
and is not trans and is not even gay or
lesbian or gender non-conforming as far
as anyone knows and you know what that
means here's new newsweek with the
latest article
they say quote mike richards stepped
down friday from his recently announced
appointment as jeopardy hosts due to
controversial comments he made years ago
now some people on social media are
calling on mayam bialik who was hired to
host the primetime version of the show
and specials to do the same
yes she has to go too
why well they went looking for reasons
and they discovered that about nine
years ago
she said that she didn't want to get her
kids vaccinated
okay that's how much they're scraping
the barrel right now to find a reason
that's it
she expressed some measure of vaccine
hesitancy nearly a decade before kova 19
existed
and that's their pretense for calling
for her ouster
but the real reason is that she is by
the canceled mob's estimation too
straight and too white
the mob has decided that the true host
of jeopardy the man who is destined for
the position as as if it is written in
the stars is levar burton known to my
generation as the man from reading
rainbow the problem is that lavar burden
tried out for the gig and was pretty
terrible
but this is no problem at all to the
cancel mob it doesn't matter if he's
good at it or not or if he deserves the
job on the merits
all that matters is that he's black
and having a black host of jeopardy
is the one piece missing
the one box left to check
the one thing that will finally heal our
national wounds and bring about an era
of peace and prosperity
or maybe not but it doesn't matter
the point is to impose themselves
and to bully jeopardy into selecting a
host that they prefer simply for the
sake of it
because they can
because that's what petty tyrants do
everything matters to the petty tyrant
especially the things that don't matter
at all
and that's why the cancel mob has made
jeopardy into a central battlefield and
it's also why they today paradoxically
are the ones who are
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
today on the ben shapiro show chuck
schumer dances as americans are stuck in
kabul and the biden administration has
no good answers to just why joe biden is
disconnected from reality that's today
on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen you